let's say that you normally go to bed at
10 p.m and you wake up at 6 00 a.m
but tomorrow morning you've got an early
morning flight so you have to wake up at
4 00 a.m rather than 6 a.m
how much sleep have you lost well you've
lost 2 hours of your 8 hour
night of sleep so you've lost 25
yes and no you've lost 25 of your total
sleep
but based on the structure of sleep that
we just described
you may have lost 50 60 70 of all of
your rem sleep all of your dream sleep
so there are there are real implications
to understanding that
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is a
professor of neuroscience and psychology
at the university of california berkeley
director of the center for human sleep
science and host
of the matt walker podcast dr matthew
walker
welcome to the reuben report pleasure to
be with you dave thanks for having me
well i'm thrilled that we're doing this
because as you know we're airing this in
august but right now it's the last
couple days of july i'm on my 30-day
digital and really societal uh
and i'm going to work on a lot of things
diet exercise
digital detox but also work on some
sleep stuff and that
is your area of expertise so i guess
before i ask you anything else
how does one become curious and enamored
and
uh eventually live their life to tell
people about sleep
of all things yeah i think myself like
many of my colleagues we are all
accidental sleep researchers you know i
don't think when we were kids and you
were going around the classroom and the
teacher was saying you know what would
you like to be when you grow up
no one was shooting up there and saying
i'd really love to be a sleep researcher
so um i fell into it by accident when i
was doing my phd i was
studying different types of dementia and
trying to diagnose them very early on
failing miserably and i realized i
should be measuring my patients when
they were
asleep rather than when they were awake
to measure their brain wave activity
started doing that i got some great
results and realized that was 20 years
ago
realized that at the time no one could
answer a very simple question
why do we sleep um and the best answer
we had back then was that we sleep
to cure sleepiness which is the the fat
you know that's like saying well you eat
to cure hunger
no you eat for a whole plethora of
different reasons
now 20 years later due to the work of
all of my colleagues and we've done
a little bit too i hope we've had to
upend the question
we've had to ask is there any operation
of your brain
and is there any physiological system in
your body
that isn't wonderfully hands enhanced
when you get sleep
or demonstrably impaired when you don't
get enough
and so far the answer seems to be no
yeah all right well there's a whole
bunch of questions that i want to ask
you that are going to revolve sort of
around my
sleep habits and my nap habits and
this thing this thing what's in this
coffee cup but right now which you
probably can't guess i'm so glad that
you're drinking decaffeinated
i honestly don't think i've ever yeah i
don't think i've ever had decaf but
before we get into any of any of those
specifics uh can just talk to me sort of
broadly about sleep you know we hear
about sort of like
you know the type of sleep that you're
happy having throughout the night
what's the most important when are you
getting the most restorative stuff all
that
yeah so sleep at least in human beings
and in fact in all mammalian species
is broadly separated into two types we
have
non-rapid eye movement sleep and then we
have rapid eye movement sleep
and those two types of sleep will play
out in this beautiful sort of battle for
brain domination
throughout the night and then the
cerebral war
is going to be won and lost between
non-rem
and rem every 90 minutes and then it's
just going to be replayed every 90
minutes to create your standard
sort of dave rubin sleep cycle what's
different however is the ratio of
non-rem to rem within those 90 minute
cycles
as you move across the night so what i
mean by that is
in the first half of last night the
majority of your 90-minute cycles
were comprised of lots of deep non-rem
sleep and very little rem sleep
but as you push through to the second
half of the night
that seesaw balance actually shifts
and now the majority of those 90-minute
cycles
is comprised much more of rem sleep and
rem sleep is the stage that we typically
associate with dreaming
and i mentioned this sort of
architecture not just because it's
hopefully intellectually
interesting but it has implications so
let's say that you
normally i'm just going to make this up
and we'll hopefully hear what your
actual sleep schedule is but let's say
that you normally go to bed at 10 p.m
and you wake up at 6 00 a.m
but tomorrow morning you've got an early
morning flight so you have to wake up at
4 00 a.m rather than 6 a.m
how much sleep have you lost well you've
lost 2 hours of your 8 hour
night of sleep so you've lost 25 percent
yes and no you've lost 25 of your total
sleep
but based on the structure of sleep that
we just described
you may have lost 50 60 70 of all of
your rem sleep all of your dream sleep
so there are there are real implications
to understanding that
to your point though which one is more
important
all stages of sleep are actually
important
different stages of sleep do different
things for your brain and your body
at different times of night but we need
all of them
you know if when you think about sleep
as being such an
idiotic thing to do from an evolutionary
perspective
you know if mother nature could have
said well i'm going to take these three
stages of sleep and i'm just going to
remove them so we save some time
and there's no harm to the organism then
she would have done it
hundreds millions of years ago but all
stages of sleep have been preserved
throughout the evolutionary path that
means
all of them are important and that's
exactly what we're finding
so is eight hours is that the magic
number that everybody
sort of still seems to think is like you
know for the average person eight hours
is the number that you want to get
the rain there is a range so what we
recommend right now
is somewhere between seven to nine hours
of sleep
is what the average adult seems to
require
once you get below seven we can
typically start to measure
impairments in your brain and your body
and
you know so much so based on the
evidence that the number of people who
seem to be able to survive on less than
six hours of sleep
without showing any impairment rounded
to a whole number and expressed as a
percent of the population
is actually zero interesting so
i'll give you a little bit of my
personal part of this on on the eight
hours
um when i started writing my first book
last year or really
over two years ago at this point when i
first started writing it i would find
that i was thinking about it so much
that i would go to sleep let's say
somewhere between like 11 and 12 p.m
and or you know midnight basically i'd
be thinking and then i'd wake up early
with the same thoughts on my mind so i'd
wake up at like 6 00 a.m and then from 6
a.m
till literally like 3 p.m i could just
write and write and write right
right and then it would be like man i
need a break right now and i started
taking sort of 20 minute or half hour
naps around 3 p.m
and i still try to do that i can't
always do it obviously but i try to do
that
and i'm curious does the if you can move
some of it into a nap
later in the day do you need it
continuously
that's a beautiful question so firstly
there is some
importance about the continuity of sleep
and what i mean by that is at night for
that six hours that you were getting
if it's very choppy sleep it's very sort
of staccato
and it's broken up and it's peppered
with lots of awakenings
that's not good quality sleep but let's
go
back to your example or your lived life
which is
you know six hours of sleep and then a
nap during the day is that okay
i think the first thing to note is that
we human beings may not have been
designed
in the way that most of us sleep right
now which is what we call
monophasic sleep in other words one long
single bout
of sleep at night because if i place
electrodes on your head
sometime between the sort of one to four
pm mark for most people
there is a drop in your brain's level of
alertness which and it's it's
pre-programmed it has nothing to do with
a big lunch by the way some people think
that
but you know in the afternoon in
meetings you can start to see those ugly
head bobs that sort of
you know it's a dead giveaway people are
the three o'clock feeling right didn't
uh
just five-hour energy people made an
awful lot of money on this feeling
they certainly did indeed but it's it's
genetically hardwired
as i said it's pre-programmed it happens
to all of us
what that means is that we may not have
been designed as a species to sleep in a
monophasic pattern
we may have been designed to sleep in
what we call a biphasic pattern
which is a long bout of sleep at night
just as you're getting
and then a short sort of siesta-like nap
in the afternoon
um so i think that that's perfectly fine
in fact we may be designed to do that
but naps are a double-edged sword
they're a sword there is a dark side
to naps and it's the following when you
s sort of when you're awake during the
day you build up all of this healthy
sleepiness and it's a chemical that
builds up and it's been building up in
my brain and your brain since the moment
we woke up this morning and it's called
adenosine
the more of it that builds up the
sleepier you feel and then when you
go to sleep at night the brain gets the
chance to evacuate
all of that sleep pressure all of that
adenosine so that after about eight
hours you wake up
feeling refreshed and restored the
problem with naps then
is that if you take a nap that's too
long
or too late in the afternoon or in the
evening
it just takes the edge off that
sleepiness it's a little bit like um
a valve on a steam cooker you know it
just just releases some of that steam
and so now it's harder for you to fall
asleep and then
stay asleep at night so it's a little
bit like snacking before your main meal
uh so i think the you know for you i
would say
if you are not struggling with sleep at
night and you can nap regularly during
the day
the naps of about 20 minutes sort of
sometime around
stop before about 4 p.m that's great but
if you are struggling with sleep at
night
then avoid naps during the day build up
all of that healthy sleepiness
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about
lifestyles instead of non-stop yelling
check out our lifestyle playlist and if
you want to watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
check out our full episode playlist
they're both right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe
and click the notification bell